[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ballet Theater once again presents its
annual holiday tradition The Nutcracker
was shows starting at the Smith Center
this week joining us today to tell us
all about the show from the Nevada
Ballet Theater we have Roy Kaiser Roy so
great to see you that video just makes
me happy when you hear that music you
know it's Nutcracker time right the
holidays it's the holidays in Las Vegas
well we were just talking about it you
have a huge turnout this year tell us a
little bit about the preparation for the
show and you have so many kids that are
part of it we have so many kids they're
all students from The Academy of Nevada
Ballet Theater we have over 50. wow
which is really exciting back full force
and um and then of course the
professional company which has 24
dancers from around the world uh we put
them all together we actually start our
stage rehearsals tonight children start
rehearsing in September wow September so
the company has about four weeks oh my
gosh well it all comes to life on stage
it's always so much fun to see and the
Nutcracker is a very traditional
National story but you guys always add
something different and keep it unique
every year what can we expect to see
this year you know the production that
we have here in Las Vegas is truly
unique there's not another production
like it in the world it was built and
designed for the Smith Center
specifically that magnificent theater
that we we get to call ourselves a
resident company of so it's just the
size and scope of it is really it's
quite extraordinary actually yeah the
the Smith Center as a backdrop in itself
is just beautiful and then the set and I
just love anything holiday so seeing all
those videos it just gets you in the
spirit and you guys have shows starting
this week tell us where and when people
can see you and you have a special
Christmas Eve show too right we have a
Christmas Eve show a matinee on
Christmas Eve which is always um just
everybody's ready for for the holiday so
it's very very exciting we open on the
ninth and we run through the 24th uh you
can check out all the dates on our
website nevadaballey.org well it's
incredible I hear the music again we
have the video playing you don't want to
miss the Nutcracker at the Smith Center
I feel like it's becoming part of
everyone's annual holiday traditions too
so that's really special thank you so
much for being here go see the show I
know I'm gonna go check it out
performances of The Nutcracker start
this Friday all the information on your
screen it runs through December 24th at
the Nevada ballet theater in the Smith
Center for tickets and more information
you can visit the Smithson